the Joe Rogan experience do you have
long-term plans like in terms of like
what you want to accomplish as a a guy
who makes movies well yes and no I mean
I don't have a I'm not trying to gear up
towards making bigger films because I
know I wouldn't work in that system
because it's just now I don't want to
make things by committee I would like
this is the [ __ ] up crazy thing I want
to do and I don't want to water because
I know so many people that'll be like
like our friend Tom Papa I remember him
telling me about his TV show come to
Papa that it was like this certain idea
he said by the time the TV people
watered it down and changed it gets on
the airs like well so far removed from
the original idea yeah that I don't you
know I don't want to do that and you
know and so I would rather my goal is
just get it made whatever it takes I'm
worried about
don't try to be blockbuster guy I don't
care I mean I've you know had the
Halloween movies we're on four thousand
screens it was like the number one movie
made oh but it didn't make me any
happier it's just about making the thing
where I can look anyway I love it I'm
done cuz you know that's at this stage
that's what I want to do yeah that the
genre is still so attractive but there's
just not a lot of those examples other
than like well your films are probably
the most prominent currently well I mean
if everything's meant I mean horror
movies are big business but if they look
at it that way then they start making
them overly palatable to a wide audience
this types of horror movies though you
know there's like supernatural horror
movies there's monster movies but then
there's like homicidal maniac movies
this is so much [ __ ] redneck homicides
that I mean who's that's my job you know
it's like The Hills Have Eyes Yeah right
and you there you go right I mean it's
like that kind of psychopath Chainsaw
Massacre type [ __ ] I love white-trash
type stuff well the carnie because
that's just yeah I was that typical kid
who worshiped Evel Knievel I mean that
hit me that
be a movie they're happy a [ __ ] movie
man I worked with his son I work with
Robby Bobby Knievel and during the Fear
Factory days oh really I did something
on fear factor yeah it was cool he's a
nice guy
but you know I was like damn dude your
dad was a [ __ ] psycho yes [ __ ] that
guy subjected his body to it's crazy and
when you watch that [ __ ] and he watched
the Philadelphia Flyers that [ __ ]
mental it was not just a little kid
watch an Evel Knievel and listening to
Alice Cooper and watching hockey fights
and that determines who you become yeah
Evel Knievel was just I mean there's a I
think it was a Rolling Stone piece of
his body where they showed all of his
x-rays and all of the raising bone
breaks and steel rods that were various
bones that were screwed together and
like [ __ ] man what kind of pain was this
guy in I don't know I mean did you see
there's a fairly new documentary I think
it's called beam Knievel I think it's
amazing well it's maybe a couple years
old actually
but um yeah just any one of those
crashes I think this is a famous one in
London and he jumps over the
double-decker buses and you can see him
land and the bike looks like it's made
out of rubber and he looks like he's
made everything like it looks like every
bone in his body
just broke and that's not you know
that's gonna do it again and do it again
Oh God I mean that was his thing imagine
that being your thing your thing is you
fly through the air on something that's
supposed to stay on the ground a
full-size Harley that's not made for
jumping or doing anything at all or
landing for that matter doesn't have any
particularly like bouncy shocks or
anything it's just hitting like cool
Katan and just oh my god yeah it's it's
a weird thing to be that guy because
there was I mean there was some people
in the past that had done some pretty
interesting [ __ ] and risked their lives
but he was doing it consistently with an
engine that was like I think about him
it's like and he was like one of the
most famous people in America yeah with
the like married in flag suit yeah is
like the Fonz and Knievel I know
area being kiddie but you gotta see that
a fancy wow that's amazing
Wow and there's stuff in there that kind
of blew my mind cuz we all remember the
Snake River Canyon yes but they were
showing how out of control it was with
the people that showed up and were so
drunk and the crowds were fighting and
crazy just on the road it's it mental
like just what's going on around the the
event that's one of those things you
can't really do today the same way like
if someone jumps over things today it's
like so many people are jumping like
you're not gonna get famous that way
because they think about the just the
bananas [ __ ] those BMX guys do with
their fo yeah three times in the air
it's commonplace
ya know watch an Evel Knievel's like
watching the original King Kong with
your kids it's like oh that was a big
deal once he jumped seven buses whatever
I did it on my bike yeah that would be a
great film I don't know what you have to
do now catch bullets with your bare
hands you know well now there's people
doing parkour and climbing buildings
with no ropes that's like you ever
watched that kid Alex Honnold do you
know you know he's the free solo the
free solo guy yeah oh I still haven't
seen that yet better he's so nice and so
normal when you talk to him I've had him
on the podcast a couple of times and I'm
like how are you the guy that's wanting
to climb the faces [ __ ] cliffs and
some of them weird they're they're not
straight up and down they're holding on
by a finger let's get like hands wedged
in these crackling look at that picture
yeah that's my that doesn't make you
[ __ ] your pants and he's getting older
and he's starting to get injured now too
and you know he's for the first time in
his life he's had you know like you know
for a long time he had no injuries no
problems and he's always been doing this
a long time now his body's not holding
up the way it used to when do you retire
like when are you Muhammad Iyer little
Knievel and you know it's time the
finger slips yeah that's when you retire
I mean that's what all of the people
that have done it before him think they
think look this is gonna end badly yeah
you know it's
it's crazy to be known as the guy who's
doing something that scares the [ __ ] out
of everybody yeah you're the guy that
everybody's watching to eventually fall
look at that
like look at the angle that doesn't even
seem possible
well he's incredibly strong his hands
like he's a slender thin guy but he has
gorilla hands yeah the fat-ass fingers
and he just can shove them into these
cracks and hang on in place he was
telling me a story about how he was free
solo climbing this one mountain when he
realized you know like [ __ ] 300 feet
up that he forgot his powder so he's got
no chalk so he's you know things are
getting slippery he's climbing and he
finds these guys that are connected to
ropes halfway up and he says hey I don't
have any powder can I borrow your chalk
I said I guess that's trot bag he makes
it all the way to the top and leaves the
chalk bag at the top for the guy it's
like one of those guys like ropes as
he's going by no rope so much [ __ ]
chalk like you know like if you ever
lifted weights like with that bar gets
slippery it sucks like you need chalk
yeah to grip things right so you can you
could really get a hold of stuff but
that's just weights you could put the
weights the worst fall is gonna be three
feet to the floor
[ __ ] I can't even watch his dime like my
hands are sweating right now thinking
about it I haven't watched that but I
got two and everyone's always talking
about no it's an amazing documentary but
he said just a fascinating guy because
it doesn't make sense he's not like some
steve-o type guy a maniac and just like
always trying to freak people out and do
the next thing no I'm gonna rock it on a
sharpened card yeah crashed into a brick
wall
exactly exactly like when steve-o comes
up with ideas like he'll tell him to me
I'm like don't do that don't do that man
yeah stop doing that
oh but I get it that's who he is he's an
he's a legitimate bona fide maniac
yeah Alex Honnold guys so calm and
peaceful you know he said like he's like
well you know I'm pretty mellow you know
it's like when the whole thing is pretty
mellow it's like when things go wrong
that's when it's not mellow like oh god
yeah yeah
everything is
[Laughter]
[Applause]